في الضفه الغربيه اعلن الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني اصابه شابين بشض قصف مسيره
اسرائيليه داخل مخيم طول كرم جروح احدهما
خطيره وكان مراسل الجزيره افاد بتجدد
الاشتباكات على مدخل مخيم طولكرم اثناء
انسحاب قوات الاحتلال من مخيم نور شمس
ويشار الى ان مخيم نور شمس شهد مواجهات مع
قوات الاحتلال منذ السابع من اكتوبر
الماضي مما ادى لاستشهاد 24 فلسطينيا هذا
هو الاقتحام الرابع للمخيم خلال
اسبوعين وينضم الان الينا من امام خيم نور
شمس في طول كرم مراسل الجزيره ليث جعار
ليث اذا الاقتحام الرابع لمخيم نور شمس
ضعنا في صوره ما يجري حولك
تفضل نعم بالفعل قوات الاحتلال لا تزال
متواجده حتى هذه اللحظه في مخيم نور شمس
حيث تشهد في هذه اللحظات المنطقه اشتباكا
مسلحا عنيفا منذ قرابه النصف ساعه اشتدت
وتيرته في هذه المنطقه وسط يعني انفجارات
ل عده عبوات ناسفه في المنطقه واستهداف كل
المارين من هذا الطريق القناصه
الاسرائيليه المتواجده في هذه المنطقه
نرصد هنا على امتداد هذا الطريق هنا عند
المدخل الرئيسي لمخيم نور شمس حيث هنا
يعني بدات العمليه العسكريه ومن هذا
الطريق بدات العمليه العسكريه ليله امس
الاشتباكات لا تزال متواصله جيش
الاحتلال مخيم لكنه لا يزال حتى هذه
اللحظه في احد احياء
المخيم الاحجار الذي يشهد في هذه الاثناء
اشتباكات مسلحه عنيفه
وا يعني عشرات الطلقات التي خرجت من
المقاومين باتجاه اليه الاحتلال اثناء
محاوله انسحاب او على ما يبدو انه هناك
انسحاب حقيقي لجيش الاحتلال من المنطقه
بعد عمليه عسكريه استمرت لاكثر من 12 ساعه
في مخيم نور شمس ومدينه طول كرم على حد
سواء هنا في هذه المنطقه بدا الفلسطينييون
فعليا بالخروج من منازلهم في هذه اللحظات
بعد ان بدا الاحتلال بالانسحاب بشكل كامل
من المنطقه ومن محيط مخيم نور شمس و بعد
محاوله استهداف الفلسطينيين لعده مرات
هناك استهداف قبل قليل كان بطائره مسيره
في مخيم طول كرم ادى ل
اصابه اثنين على الاقل من الفلسطينيين
وصفت جراحهم
بالطفيفة النور شمس للعمليه العسكريه
ولجيش الاحتلال الذي لا يزال يتواجد في
بعض او في منطقه حي المحجر وسط اشتباكات
مسلحه قبل قليل لم تنتهي بعد
وهناك وصول لبعض التعزيزات لسحب ما تبقى
من القوات الراجله في منطقه حي المحجر 12
ساعه والعمليه العسكريه على ما يبدو على
مشارف هاء وخلفت هذه العمليه تدمير لعدد
كبير من الطرقات في داخل مخيم نور شمس
وايضا لعدد من المنازل في المخيم اشكرك
على هذه التفاصيل ليث جعار من امام مخيم
نور شمس في طورك